Okay. Uh, we are going to continue our
scaling journey. Uh, today is a bit of a
grab bag of stuff. I mean, we're really
going to talk about some of the more
advanced details of scaling laws and how
we scale up models. Um, and in doing so,
we're going to cover what I feel like
are some important details in how, you
know, you would scale up a language
model in practice. Okay.
So, you know, we might want to ask some
questions like, is the scaling law stuff
that you talked about two lectures ago,
you know, does it actually work at real
building open source model scales?
Um, it would be nice if we could
optimize some of this. There's a lot of
like learning rate tricks and other
things that people do, um, that I think
you should know as people that are
informed about how to build, uh,
language models. So, we'll talk about
some of these optimization details.
Um, and then, I think the last thing I
want to talk about is
when we scale up, there are certain
things that are going to be a little bit
trickier to tune. Um, we know that
optimizers and optimizer behavior is
going to be actually pretty scale
sensitive. And because of that, things
like initializations, learning rates,
batch size, those we need to carefully
think about as a function of scale. So,
we will talk about how to think about
those, um,
carefully.
Okay. So, up until now, most of our
discussions, uh, what I would is what I
would call like the classical, you know,
scaling laws canon. We talked about
Kaplan, we talked about, oh, even
Hessness, um, and then, you know, the
Chinchilla paper. Right? So, so, we're
up to date with, I don't know, 2022 or
something.
Um, since then, you know, there have
been a number of scaling papers that are
published by people who train big
models. Um,
although I think the number of such
papers have decreased in recent years,
and most of them have come out of the
open source community in China.
Um, and so, today I want to talk about,
um, a number of these that I've sort of
curated and selected, um, to give you a
sense of, you know, what the scaling at
the frontier, at least open frontier,
look like. Um, what are the things that
these people care about or worry about,
and like what would what would you need
to do to sort of speed run your way from
Chinchilla all the way to, let's say,
Kimmy K2, um, most recent release that
has some scaling details.
Okay, so that's going to be the first
part of this lecture. We're going to go
through a couple of papers, and we're
going to go through the details.
The second part is going to be a
discussion of, um, optimizers and
initializations. Um, and remember I
spent a non-trivial amount of time, um,
two lectures ago on the selection of
batch sizes. Um, that's going to be an
important factor, and it's also going to
be important, um, thinking about how
we're going to tune things like learning
rates. Those are very sensitive, um,
very important to get right. And so, it
turns out that a lot of effort has been
invested into getting those things
right, and we will talk about some of
the techniques to do so. And this may in
fact even be useful in your day-to-day
lives of training, um, various language
models, cuz they'll give you a sense of
how to change your hyper-parameters in
your experiments as you scale up or
down.
Okay.
Um, so I'm going to spend a non-trivial
amount of time talking about two papers
in particular. Um, they're not the
newest papers.
Um, they're not necessarily the most,
actually DeepSeek one might be one of
the more detailed ones,
um, most detailed scaling paper in
general, but I think this is hits a
sweet spot. So, both of these papers are
kind of serious scaling investigations
from people who build, you know,
reasonably high-performance models. And
importantly, they take pretty different
approaches to some of the key questions
that we will ask today. And so, I think
they're a good way to motivate a lot of
the rest of the lecture. So, I'm going
to talk about these two. First one's
MiniCPM, um, this was, I think, back in
2024, high-performance small language
model, um, and DeepSeek, you all are now
familiar with this. I no longer have to
justify why I'm talking about DeepSeek,
which is great.
Um, we'll start by talking about
MiniCPM, though. Um, I I do like this
paper, um, especially when it first came
out. It felt very fresh and new and like
very, you know, at the cutting edge. Um,
even in 2026, I feel like a lot of the
things that the MiniCPM folks did is
very informative to us. Um, I'll talk
about this later as I get to the newer
papers, but I think it's kind of
becoming the case that a lot of this
like
classic scaling stuff, like how you set
learning rates, how do you do
Chinchilla? Um, those kinds of things I
think are now taken for granted. Like
everyone just assumes that you know how
to do those things. And so people don't
really talk about those as much anymore
in the papers. So it's really nice to
talk about, um, some of these like older
papers for that reason.
Um, so MiniCPM is an effort by, you
know, a bunch of industry academic
partnerships folks, um, over in the
Chinese open source community to come up
with a high performance smallish
language model. And at the time when
this came out, um, it was basically
state-of-the-art for like the 1 to 2
billion parameter bracket. Um, nowadays,
you know, Gemma and other models, Gemma,
and other models that 2B or 3B are going
to be higher performance, but these are,
you know, competitive well-trained
models, at least those at 2024
standards.
Um, so how do you train these models?
Okay.
As I said before, um, you know, we have
to get some of these like scaling
parameters right. And one of the things
that I'll talk about today, um, that
I'll emphasize quite a bit, um, is
initializations are very important.
Initializations are important because
they allow you to, um, make certain
hyper parameters less scale dependent.
Um, so the first technique that I want
to talk about from this MiniCPM paper,
um, is a special class of
initializations called μP. Um, so μP,
the whole point of this approach is to
say, I want to make sure that my optimal
learning rate is the same as I scale up
and down, right? I talked about this
very briefly, um, in in the two lectures
ago, so you should hopefully remember
that a little bit. But this is kind of
the the first real instantiation that
we're going to talk
What does that look like specifically?
Um, the MiniCPM paper has a nice list of
things, you know, to do. Um, so they
scale the embedding output, they scale
the residual connections by the square
root of number of layers, they scale the
initialization of all their matrix shape
tensors by the fan in fan out ratio. Um,
they scale the learning rates of tensors
and and you know, you should pay
attention to this one cuz this is exotic
if you aren't used to like per parameter
learning rates. Um, and then they also
scale the LM heads. We'll talk about why
you do these things or like how you
derive this particular set of scalings.
Um, suffice to say that, you know,
you're just going to change up how
you're going to do your initializations
and your learning rates a little bit in
the hopes of stabilizing your learning
rates a little bit.
Um, and of course we're training a small
model here, but we're still wanting to
do a nice scaling strategy, right? Like
part of the point of the study is not
that you want to brute force, you know,
a 1.5B model like training hundreds of
them. You want to get the hyper
parameters exactly right the first time,
so you're going to train a bunch of much
smaller models, um, and then get a
scaling ladder up all the way to your
target size um, of 5X or so, right? Um,
and so there's about a 5X gap between
the biggest model they train on their
ladder and the actual model that they're
going to finally release, right? Um,
and their goal is going to be to nail
down I think what most people consider
to be the sensitive parameters, like
optimal batch size, learning rate, um,
and then the token to size ratio that we
talked about at Chinchilla, um, they
sort of also want to replicate a
Chinchilla analysis. Much less important
to us, um, now and and probably to you
even if you're training, but I'm going
to talk about it regardless cuz there's
one important thing in in the way they
do that and that I think is very
informative and useful.
Okay.
So, um, as I said earlier, right? The
whole point of going through this weird
initialization or non-standard
initialization called μP is to try to
make the optimal learning rates stable.
Um, is it? Um, at least in sort of the
MiniCPM case, the answer is yes. Um in
fact, it's very, very clean in their
experiments. They sweep learning rate um
across a variety of models, so each line
is a model size. Um the minimal loss is
basically right on 10 to the -2. Um I
guess the minimum is slightly shifted
for the smallest model, but I mean even
then it's quite close to the minimum. Um
so this is, you know, a nice success
case of the μP approach. We will talk
about several other models and other
papers that use μP. Um this is not the
only way to do it, but this is one
effective way to do it. And if you can
get something like this, now you've kind
of removed the need to tune the learning
rate.
But of course, even if you have a nice
parameterization that fixes your
learning rate to a single sort of
optimum, your optimal batch size is
still not going to be kind of the same.
So the the batch size actually varies as
a function of uh both data set size and
uh model size. Um so in their case, you
know, they run these sort of model
training runs. So each column of points
that you see uh on these plots is a is a
is a training run. So they they have a
fixed batch size and they increase the
number of tokens processed, I guess from
bottom to top. Um and then they ask,
"Okay, we've done many of these training
runs. What is the optimal batch size
fitting sort of these quadratic sort of
curves onto each of these sort of uh
uh lines over here, this sort of equal
loss contour?"
What they find is sort of this kind of
optimal batch size scaling as a function
of the number of tokens processed, and
they do this across different model
sizes.
Um
you know, maybe you you would not be
surprised by this given, you know, the
nice scalings that we saw in the Kaplan
paper for critical batch sizes, but the
optimal batch size does have a sort of
power law structure with respect to the
target loss. Um
and so we kind of see exactly the Kaplan
style analysis of, you know, if your
loss is lower on the left, your batch
size should be bigger, right? Critical
batch size scaling. Um and so now given
a particular loss target, which you can,
you know, back out from the scaling
loss,
um you can basically set what the
optimal or, you know, critical batch
size is that would give you the best
trade-offs, right? So, there's a nice
clean trend here. This will let you set
batch size very easily and precisely.
Okay. So, those two, um the batch size
and the learning rate scaling, um
they're going to come back over and over
again. Those are arguably the most
important and sensitive parameters to uh
do scaling laws on. Um but, I'll talk
about one last thing in the MiniCPM
paper that I think is important. Um so,
you know, remember, like to do
Chinchilla, right? We need to train a
lot of different models. So, we're going
to, let's say, do isoflops. That means
I'm going to fix a flops budget and I'm
going to vary, you know, my trade-offs
between number of tokens uh and model
size. Um and to do that, I'm going to,
let's say, increase the amount of data I
train on, right? So, increase the number
of sequences. But, as I increase the
number of sequences, remember that each
one of these gets a different learning
rate schedule, right? You know, you're
all training on cosine learning rates.
Cosine learning rates look different.
You need to know the terminal sort of
total budget before you train in order
to have a cosine schedule, right?
Um and so, this leads to kind of a
annoying fact, which is that you just
need to keep retraining your models. If
you want to train a, you know, 8 million
sequence model, right? You can't start,
like restart from the end of a 4 million
sequence model, right? You have to just
restart from scratch because your
learning rate schedule is just
fundamentally different, right? And this
is just very annoying. It's like a
quadratic cost in some sense of doing
this um because you have to keep
restarting your runs just from the
start.
Um and this seems very wasteful, um and
I think lots of other people did, too.
Um and I think uh one of the nice
solutions from the MiniCPM paper uh is
what's now called, I think, the warm-up
stable decay learning rate, or this is,
you know, the popular term for this. Um
and it's basically a big trapezoid. Um
so, you've got a warm-up phase. The
warm-up phase is usually defined as a
constant number of steps, not as a
fraction of your your training target,
right? So, this is independent of your
training horizon. You've got a fairly
long run where you're holding the
learning rates constant. That's the
stable phase.
And then at the end you're going to
decay fairly rapidly down to zero,
right? That's the decay phase.
And generally, you know, the decay phase
is something like 10 to 20% of your
total training run, right? So you're
going to be stable for the vast majority
of your training run and then do a very
rapid decay down to usually about 10% of
your maximum learning rate at the very
end here. And that's like a very typical
warm-up
warm-up stable decay learning rate.
Okay, and why do we do this? What's the
point of doing this? Well, we do WSD
because now we can restart a run at any
point at the end of the stable phase,
right? So if I want to reuse a run and
like train it for longer, right? I'll
just roll back my training to the last
stable checkpoint
and then I'll just run the stable
learning rates forward and then re-decay
the model down to zero, right? So this
provides a very easy way for us to
essentially run sort of scale in data
experiments without constantly
re-running your experiments, right? So
you you do have to re-decay every time,
but that's maybe 10% of the total cost,
you know, it's a much better situation
to be repeatedly decaying than to
repeatedly rerun your pre-training
runs. And this is this is a very common
trick that's used in many places.
Um I'll show you I guess a performance
comparison.
Um there have been many plots of this
form. I think
who who was the most recent folks that
were were um
maybe it was Martin Jaggi and others
I think over at ETH had like an
extensive study of like WSD sort of
performance, but I think a lot of papers
have shown similar things of, you know,
you have a well-tuned cosine learning
curve. This is, you know, the orange
line over here. And then you've got
various WSD curves. And WSD curves
always look a little bit funky because
it looks like you're way under
performing until you hit the decay phase
where suddenly you kind of reclaim all
of your gains and then you sort of match
or even sometimes exceed the cosine
learning rate performance.
Um anecdotally, I think if you if you
talk to a bunch of people training
networks, I think a lot of people will
say the cosine is slightly better in
many cases, um but WSD is basically as
good in many other situations. Like it
is a very versatile default learning
rate, um doesn't necessarily suffer from
having to sort of rerun
uh if you want to just continue runs.
Um it is very cool though to see, you
know, just how much of an impact
learning rate decay has. If you haven't,
you know, played with that before. Like
it This part of decaying the learning
rate is just incredibly important to
sort of getting the final sort of
annealing parts of your uh training uh
together.
Okay. So,
that's the comparison there. Um okay, so
now that we're equipped with WSD style
learning rates, you know, Chinchilla
style analyses are actually very easy.
What you're going to do is you're going
to, you know, essentially run one long
run and then you'll just sort of rewind
the checkpoints and then repeatedly
decay. And that will give you sort of
sweeps along the data dimension, and
then you'll also do sweeps along the
model dimension. You can do isoflops or
any other kind of analysis that you
would like. Um the MiniCPM authors, for
whatever reason, choose to try to
replicate methods one and three, which
to me are the the least reliable of the
Chinchilla methods, but, you know, they
do get fairly nice-looking scaling
curves. Um if you look at the MiniCPM
uh
sort of Chinchilla method one, they they
see like nice lower envelopes that look
mostly linear across these, which is
good. Um and then method three, they get
nice smooth scaling for the most part in
both sort of the the compute to
non-embedding parameter trade-off. So,
um
it seems like for the most part they get
reasonable Chinchilla-looking fits. One
thing I will point out, um
is that they get pretty different
exponents for their overall joint fit um
compared to Chinchilla. Um they claim in
the paper that this means that they
should be be with way more tech pieces
of text than uh Chinchilla. It is highly
unclear to me whether this is a really
true or whether their Chinchilla fits
are a little bit strange relative to
um the original Chinchilla paper.
Okay, I'll stop here for a moment in
case someone has questions about
MiniCPM. Maybe the main couple of things
to take away is one is, you know, the
use of μP is a useful trick, I guess, to
try to stabilize how your learning rate
changes over scales. And then the second
thing maybe to remember is the WS
learning rate. That's just like a very
common trick. You should all kind of
know about this learning rate. That's a
basic, you know, thing to know. Okay.
Good. All right.
So then I'll move on to uh DeepSeek. Um
this is the kind of, you know, original
DeepSeek paper um before, you know, they
started talking about MoEs and all these
other sort of very cool things. Um and I
think even at the very first DeepSeek
paper, you could kind of tell that these
were very serious people because I think
DeepSeek LLM, you know, even now, is I
think one of the more nicely executed
scaling analyses in the open world,
right? And I feel like they have lots of
great taste in the experiments that they
run. So even before, you know, uh R1 and
so on came out, it was like kind of
clear that these people were were going
places. All right.
Um so DeepSeek takes a very different
scaling strategy than uh MiniCPM and and
several others in trying to optimize
their hyperparameters. Like they're not
going to really do μP, right? They're
not going to do this like interesting
scaling adjustments. Um instead, they're
going to directly try going to try to
fit a scaling law to estimate both the
optimal batch size and the optimal
learning rate, right? Um so we know that
the learning rate and batch sizes should
actually change with scale. But if the
way in which they change are
predictable, just like a scaling law,
then we're good to go, right? Like we
don't really need to to worry about very
much. Um so what they do is they
basically run extensive grid searches at
various different scales, and they try
to find the optimum, right? So this is
an example of the kind of thing they're
doing. You know, they're sweeping
learning rates, they're sweeping batch
sizes, and they're looking at sort of
the terminal loss
if they're processing a particular
number of tokens, right? So, they fix
the compute and then they vary these
two.
They'll do this across several different
scales and then they'll basically try to
identify what the lowest loss is, in
this case the lightest color, right? So,
they'll put a little star there
and then they'll do this across scales.
So, if you do you know, this across
sufficiently many scales, you will get a
plot that looks a little like this,
right? And this plot is saying, "Okay,
I'm going to vary
my non-embedding training flops across
some range." And you can kind of see
these gray dots over here, right? And
I'm going to vary as I vary this, my
optimal batch size will change.
Remember, the optimal batch size is
derived by looking at these big grids
and and kind of finding the minimizer,
right?
And I will get something that kind of
looks like a line, right? The optimal
batch size should scale with my
non-embedding flops.
And similarly for my optimal learning
rate, right? I'll get a bunch of gray
dots in my sort of non-embedding flops
range and then I can fit a line to that
to try to estimate what my optimal
learning rate should look like, right?
So, this is
fairly nice.
And I guess one thing I'll point out is
you know, their their full runs are on
the star, right? These are the runs that
they chose. At higher flops, they they
have much higher batch sizes and much
lower learning rates, right? The stars
are the things they actually ran for
their their big runs.
These fits look reasonable for the
batches, right? This kind of does look
like a line. The one on the learning
rate, I'm not quite sure that
constitutes you know, the best linear
fits that I've seen in my life.
But I guess it works, it's probably
fine, right? Like the models do train,
the models do get reasonable things. Um,
think this is the one I would say like
drawback of the learning rates approach.
It's not really clear that if you try to
do this grid search kind of thing unless
your grid is in the right place, you've
got a lot of quantization error, and
then you're not getting very good uh
scaling law fits, and you end up with
kind of something that looks like a
arbitrary linear thing going on.
Okay.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
>> Okay, for the same number of training
flops, there you get multiple data
points with a large range of optimal
learning rates.
>> Why is it that you get a large range of
optimal learning rates for different
training flops? Is that Is that the
question on the Y-axis over here?
Yeah.
Um, so the reason I think there is
because of the the changes to uh the
model sizes and things like this.
Um,
and so, you know, 2024 was back in the
era where I think every open model
builder was replicating the entire
scaling law stack. And so, you know,
DeepSeek also complements um
the, you know, like like learning rate
analysis with
uh basically a Chinchilla replication.
Um, and to do that, they're also going
to do the same thing as MiniCPM. They're
going to follow the WSD style learning
rate. Um, they have a weird little
variation where they do two decay phases
instead of one.
I am not really sure why this is. Um,
it hasn't really been a thing that has
taken off afterwards, but it is a thing
that they do. Regardless, the whole
point here is to say WSD is an effective
approach, and you can use that to
replicate Chinchilla.
Um, and DeepSeek, you know, has much
nicer scaling curves
um than MiniCPM because of their choice
to go with uh isoflops, so they get
these very nice, you know, clean sweeps
um across the the fixed flops ranges,
and then they also get fairly nice and
clean uh Chinchilla style tradeoffs
um as before.
So, this allows them to essentially
replicate the Chinchilla results um and
get you know a similar kind of of a data
model scaling law.
Really, the point that I'm showing with
this is just to say, "Look, the
Chinchilla laws have been replicated by
other people at large ish compute
ranges. So, that analysis is generally
sound."
Finally, I think you know this is kind
of the
I'm a little bit sad that these kinds of
plots are now somewhat rare in
open-source release papers, but you know
this is really the the final punchline
of a lot of scaling law work, right? You
train a bunch of small curated models,
you know, at smaller compute ranges and
then you kind of like draw out the power
law and then in the end you get
something pretty close to reality if you
scale out enough, right? So, the two
stars are the models that they actually
trained. The gray dots are their scaling
law fits
and they're getting like pretty good
predictions on their star. I mean it
could be better, but it's not bad at
all. And so, they're able to get some
pretty accurate scaling law predictions
on real, you know, open-source models
that they've trained.
Okay, I'm actually I'll stop here.
If people have questions about the
DeepSeek stuff,
feel free to ask them. I think my
one-line summary here is to say, you
know, this is the other approach to
dealing with the sensitive hyper
parameters. You can either attempt to
stabilize them or you can attempt to
just scaling law fit them, right? And
then just go with the scaling law. And
DeepSeek it represents the more like fit
the scaling law approach to this
problem.
Good. Okay.
So, there are other models,
more recent ones that have you know nice
scaling laws that they talk about. As I
said before though, I think a lot of
this work is now you know kind of
What's the it's kind of like all known
to everybody and so no one is really
putting a lot of this stuff into like
big sections into the paper. So, if you
look at Qwen 2.5, they say something
like, "Okay, well, we need to tune some
optimal hyper parameters like batch
sizes and learning rates. So, we do a
bunch of scaling experiments to figure
out what the optimum are and then we
have a scaling law and we predict the
optimum and then we're able to do that
even for MOEs, right? So, this is
basically the same thing as the deep
seek analysis, right? That they're
talking about in Gwen 2.5. Um same thing
with Gwen 3, right? By the time it's
Gwen 3, you know, they say, all right,
we've already figured out what to do in
Gwen 2.5. We're just doing exactly the
same thing, right? So, this has become
part of a very standard recipe um that
you use in order to nail down the
optimum optimal learning rates and
batches.
Um
Chinchilla 2 um is probably the newest
paper that I'll talk about of the
series. Um at this point I'm just going
to quickly go through several papers.
Mainly to give you sort of um overview
of what people are doing in terms of
scaling work in the in the open-source
model releases.
Um so, Chinchilla 2 and a few others um
have focused on essentially MOE scaling
laws. So, you know, it's 2026, most
people know you know how to do a
Chinchilla scaling law or even a
learning rate scaling law. What things
are new? Well, a lot of these companies
are now switching to MOEs, fully
switching to MOEs, right? And if you're
doing that, you really want to know, you
know, am I training the right amount of
active parameters? And so, they're doing
things like, okay, we're going to vary
the flops and look at my losses and I'm
going to do so for different levels of
sparsity so that I can figure out how
much sparsity helps or hurts my losses.
And their conclusion, of course, is as
if you look at the different sparsity
levels, the more sparse your network,
right? The better your validation loss
given a flop. Unsurprising. But now, the
fact that they can quantitatively know
what the relationship is between
sparsity and loss means that they can
make sort of more rational decisions
about, you know, how much sparsity to
put into their model. And they they look
at this and they say, okay, what we're
going to do is we're going to use a
sparsity of 48 because at that point
we're hitting diminishing returns on our
scaling loss, right? Um so, you can kind
of see how this kind of analysis is used
to justify different architectural
decisions across different open source
releases.
Hunyuan, which is another
open source MOE from a few years ago
now,
they do a very similar thing, right?
Like I think every company once they
switch to the MOE has to do this kind of
like a MOE scaling law to figure out how
the number of activated parameters or
the amount of sparsity changes training
loss and then they kind of redo a lot of
these analyses. So, for example, in in
Hunyuan's case they end up with like a
96 data point per active parameter
ratio. In their case, they're fixing the
sparsity level and so that's not a thing
that they're searching over.
Um, Llama 3 also has some nice scaling
laws.
Unfortunately,
they're not particularly useful ones.
They do iso-flop style scaling and and
get slightly different but similar
ratios for token to model.
The most interesting thing that they do
in terms of scaling in Llama 3 is the
the plot on the right here, which is,
you know, they have the usual scaling
law, which is the left panel. That's
saying if I have more compute than the
log prob on the the sort of answer for a
benchmark sort of decays consistently.
And on the right side they show, okay,
well, you know, if you have better sort
of log loss than the downstream accuracy
also goes up, right? So, they're
basically saying, well, we can just fit
a sigmoid on these purple points and
that might give us a sense of like how
good these different models are. You can
kind of see there's systematic
deviations from the curve, so I don't
really know if I would really buy that
this curve is like the one truth that's
going on, but you can certainly see that
it is consistent with a sigmoidal
scaling mapping from the loss to the
accuracy, which I think is very useful,
right? Because we've been talking only
about kind of log losses, but there is a
tight coupling in some cases or in many
cases between log losses and downstream
accuracy.
Okay.
And then sort of for one last um
paper that I want to talk about for
scaling, MiniMax zero one from last year
had this nice set of scaling experiments
where they were doing the exact kind of
thing I was saying
is a useful affordance of scaling from
two lectures ago. And that is
architecture variations. And so they
wanted to understand, okay, I have
lightning attention which is like some
kind of a linear attention architecture.
I have a soft max version like full
attention. I have a hybrid version that
mixes the two. How do these things
scale? You know, is it the case that if
I scale up one of them will get much
worse than the other?
And so you know, you can kind of see
this they're replicating essentially the
Kaplan plots of like as I increase
flops, you know, how do the learning
curves change? And you know, is the
number of parameters that I need
different for different levels of
compute for these different
architectures? And the answer is for the
most part kind of no that you know,
hybrid and lightning and soft max are
all comparable for the most part and
they require similar model sizes. And
this set of plots is used to justify
their use of the hybrid architecture in
the actual deployed system. Right? So
this is exactly the kind of
decision-making that you would do based
upon a scaling law.
Okay.
So that's basically what I wanted to
cover for the the recent scaling law
recipes from the various companies. So
the two things as I said before for the
deep sea recipe right, really the key
thing is the scaling analysis on the
batch and learning rate. This is the
scaling based approach. And MiniCPM
follows a more of a μP style approach to
to try to get invariances. Um and then
you know, we see some trends. We see
that like Kimmy and Quen and others are
doing or in Hunyuan are doing these like
MoE scaling experiments as they switch
to MoEs. We see some architecture work
by MiniMax.
Um and we also see you know, some
iso-flops analysis being replicated by
several others.
And the to return to our previous point,
right? The point here is I think a lot
of companies are now less detailed
because the core scaling machinery like,
you know, doing Chinchilla or doing
learning rate scaling is now fairly well
understood by everybody. So, there's no
necessarily
extra value in, you know, showing those
experiments or some of these releases.
Or at least that's my guess for why we
have much fewer of these kinds of
experiments in the release.
Okay.
I'll take 1 minute and then sort of
pause and let you digest and ask a
question or two in case you have
questions for this part.
>> Okay.
So, all these cover the the pre-finished
stage. So, my question is
what changes or what do not change when
now post-training is kind of
standardized process for quality?
>> Yes, the question was about
what hap- what changes about this when
you do or when you think about
post-training, I guess, broadly? I think
that's still a big open question.
There's no great way to do like fully
integrated scaling with like
post-training accounted for because
post-training like can sometimes really
change the nature of like, you know,
what pre-training you should do. The
closest things that I can think of to
thinking about post-training is there's
been some work on like understanding
like coverage or like, you know,
diversity notions in pre-training that
would help predict what happens in
post-training, but it's still pretty
nascent work. I don't think there's any
good answer to the question of like what
do we do about, you know, synergy with
post-training.
Cool.
Okay.
So, now we're going to talk about the
other piece.
So, I think the two remaining parts of
this lecture
kind of map on cleanly to the two
examples. So,
I'm going to talk about one approach,
one set of approaches, which is about
scaling laws for learning rates, batch
sizes, and optimizers, right? That kind
of corresponds to the to the deep seek
approach to the world. Um and then I'm
going to talk about kind of the μP
stuff, right? Like the That's kind of
the mini CPM approach to the world. Can
we just reparameterize everything to
make it so that we don't have to worry
about scale. So,
we're going to now talk about kind of
the deep seek approach. Um how do we
scale learning rate properly? Um and so,
there's going to be a hyperparameter
part and a optimizer choice part.
Um and I'm going to draw quite a bit
from this pretty recent preprint um from
the StepFun folks folks. Um
I don't think there's like a great, you
know, really truly like reliable, robust
uh study on hyper parameters, um
especially learning rates. Um but this
is probably getting somewhat close. The
StepFun folks train, you know, credible
large models and release them. And they
burned a ton of compute in grid
searching the space of hyper parameters
in the scaling law studies. So, I'll go
through this and like, you know, show
you some intriguing empirical phenomena
about how learning rates, batch size,
and all those affect downstream losses.
Okay.
Um so, lots of people have talked about
lots of different ways of scaling
learning rate and batch sizes as roughly
as a function of compute. Um and, you
know, the StepFun survey not survey
paper, the hyperparameter tuning paper
has this very nice table that like
captures a lot of this. Um and I'll
point out a couple of different things.
Um some of this we already know. So, the
very top row, this OpenAI scaling law,
this is from Kaplan. Uh if you look at
the batch size over there, notice how it
says like 2 e 18, you know, capital L to
the exponent. That's critical batch
sizes, right? It's basically saying, you
know, you should scale your batch size
as a function of your terminal loss.
Great, right? Um deep seek we just saw,
right? This is kind of the the um
compute-based scaling laws for both
learning rate and batch size. I mean,
there's been a couple of other folks
that have proposed various kinds of
scaling, including MiniCPM, which we
talked about as well.
Um
you another important thing that I want
to point out is that these, you know,
formulas for learning rate and batch
sizes, they don't even have the same
inputs, right? Like people don't even
seem to agree what are the variables
that should affect these learning rates.
Like, you know, the OpenAI one is
terminal loss, whereas the the Step One
folks,
they claim that the right batch size
scaling is a function of the data,
right? So, there's a lot of different
sort of disagreements about the nature
of scaling for hyperparameters.
Um and I think one thing I'll say as I
go through this is not to take even this
last row as kind of gospel, right? A lot
of these things are are pretty brittle
in many ways, but the experiments and
the phenomena are things that you can
learn well from. So, I'll do that.
Um so, the design of this paper is very
similar to the DeepSeek one. Like,
they're just going to train a ton of
models to, you know, grid out both the
learning rate space and the batch size
space and do them across a range of
models and range of
data set sizes. And by doing so, they
they hope to essentially saturate the
hyperparameter space for a set of small
models and then nail down what the
optimum is. And much like in the
DeepSeek design, they're going to be,
you know, after they grid up the space
you know, in this case they have a
contour plot, but the underlying objects
are just they run a bunch of models.
They aim to try to minimize sort of the
losses, right? And the contour plots are
quite nice. I feel like they give a good
visualization.
Um they ran a pretty high resolution
grid, and thanks to that, one of the
things that we can see is that they can
actually plot out a fairly high
resolution contour of what the
hyperparameter space looks like. In this
case, this is a slice at 1B parameters
and 100B tokens, I believe.
And you can sort of
see on the right side that surface is
the hyperparameter sort of landscape,
you know, as a function of the batch
size, which is kind of you know, on one
axis and learning rate, which is the
other axis, how does the loss change if
you fix
the total amount of data in the model.
Now, you know, we see that each slice,
like if you fix the batch size or you
fix a learning rate, right? Each slice
is kind of nice and convex and it's
almost even smooth. And this is quite
nice because it means that you can, you
know, kind of search for the optimal
hyperparameter, you know, fairly nicely
and you can be confident that the minima
is not too far off. This was very
jaggedy, you might have some, you know,
very serious doubts about whether this
kind of program of gridding the spaces
even viable.
Also, this should maybe give you some
nice intuition about the smoothness of
the hyperparameter space in general.
Um
and I think there's actually one really
interesting general scaling trend. And
looking at other related papers to this
topic, I think I don't know if I've seen
any contradicting evidence to this
observation.
So, I think the one thing that seems
very interesting and one of the key
takeaways of this work is essentially if
you're looking at the optimal batch
size, right? The only thing that seems
to depend on is the total amount of data
that you're training on.
So, this right hand plot is the is the
one to look at, right? So, x-axis here
is the amount of data that you're
training on. The different colored dots,
those are different models. Notice how,
you know, the different colored dots
seem to follow roughly the same trend
line here, so fairly predictable one.
And this is in log-log scale, so you you
should expect some sort of a power law
as a function of D, right? On the left
panel, we have
the dependence of learning rate and we
see that this is a very different
behavior, right? Bigger models, so if
you go from blue all the way to this
pink color, right? Bigger models have
smaller optimal learning rate and larger
amounts of data have higher optimal
learning rate, which is kind of
counterintuitive, actually.
Um,
and so this might be a little fragile.
There are other kinds of papers that
argue that the dependence on D should be
kind of reversed. Um, but the trends
here, at least on this experiment, are
quite clear.
Okay. Um, and you know,
one final thing that I kind of want to
point out is
the learning rates are actually pretty
robust. And I think this is backed up by
a lot of experiences and experiments
that people have. You know, I think
people have a sense of like, you know,
actually, as a poll, like, do people
know what a good like hyperparameter is?
Like, if you were told to train a
language model tomorrow, like, would it
be 1e-3, 1e-4, right? I feel like we
roughly have a sense of like, actually,
this range of hyperparameters for
learning rates is generally a good
starting point. Um, and that is
generally true. So, so the scaling laws
that they got, um,
you know, actually transfer over to, for
example, MOEs to a to certain extent.
The yellow stars, which might be a
little harder to see, are the
predictions from their scaling laws. The
red X's are sort of the optima that are
derived, uh, sort of directly on the
MOEs. And so, you know, you switch to an
MOE, um, you don't end up with a very
different scaling law, as long as you're
you're roughly controlling for for
active, uh, parameters. Um, the one
thing that does seem a little bit more,
you know, potentially dicey is, you
know, as you shift the training data,
the optimal learning rates and the
optimal batch sizes do shift a little
bit, right? Which means that all of
these phenomena are likely contingent.
Like, the specific numbers that are are
in these scaling laws and so on, um, are
potentially contingent to the data that
you train on, um, more so than others.
And so, uh, I want to flash this back
up, um, you know, before I sort of move
on. Right? So, you end up with some sort
of simple scaling law at the end, which
says, "Okay, batch size, you know, maybe
should be roughly square root of the
number of data times some constant. Your
learning rate should kind of scale, you
know, upwards with batch size or upwards
with data, but downwards with the model
size. And that's kind of a surprising
effect,
but you know, not maybe crazy because
these experiments often, in many cases,
are assuming like Chinchilla-like
scaling, in which case, you know, those
two would kind of cancel, and as you
increase compute, your learning rate
should go down, right?
Um hopefully that Chinchilla comment was
clear. What What I mean is when you're
scaling by Chinchilla,
N and D are sort of both driven by
compute, and as compute goes up, you
expect your learning rate to go down,
right? And so you will end up with
something like the DeepSeek law, where
the learning rate decreases with
compute, and the batch size increases
with compute, albeit with different
exponents than the DeepSeek law.
Cool.
Okay.
Um so, in some sense, this is like the
the newest and most large-scale version
of the DeepSeek analysis, and this is
one way that, you know, if you were
doing the scaling law-style approach,
you would approach this problem of
fitting a learning rate.
Okay. Um so, you know, that's the
hyperparameter story. If someone has
questions, feel free to stop me.
And then next, right after, I'm going to
move on to talking about optimizers. I
think this is one thing that I, you
know, didn't have time to talk about in
the in the architectures
lecture. That was already a pretty
packed lecture,
but I think it would be sort of a
disservice to you if I don't talk about
optimizers. And optimizers are
scale-dependent, so this is a good place
to put them and talk about some of the
latest and greatest developments in
optimizers and their relationship with
scale.
Oh, yeah.
>> Um so, I guess like
I'm trying to figure out how to
interpret this. Like, does that mean we
should just take the scaling laws that
we have and then apply them, rather than
running our own grid search?
>> Yeah, I mean, I think it depends like
what regime you're in. The question is
like, oh, sorry, I have to repeat it for
the online folks, right? Is, you know,
should we just take the scaling law and
run them, or like should we just do our
own grid search? Um you know, it does
kind of depend on the amount of compute
budget that you have, and how much you
need to nail it. Um I do think, for
example, you know, maybe the step on uh
law, if you're in the right compute
regime, like close to where they were
running the grid, these are probably
really good defaults, right? Like I
would bet on these over like something I
pick pull out of my hat. That said, you
know, if you were doing your own big
pre-training run, um you are probably
going to have minor differences, right?
Like, you know, someone might say, "I
really believe we should have a big
weight decay. My architecture has a big
weight decay." You know, we don't know
necessarily that those things are going
to scale the same, right? Um and so you
might want to actually redo a lot of
this. And this is why I think a lot of
the, you know, the the reports I showed
you were redoing Chinchilla, redoing all
these things, because there's enough
minor differences that people want to
check and make sure that they're like
roughly first order correct um with
these results. Um
I think this will come up again in this
next optimizer part, and I'll say email
this with earlier, which is, you know,
scaling laws kind of have this very
scientific feel to them. It's like, "Oh
yes, fit these lines and extrapolate
them." But ultimately, a big part of
scaling laws is still vibes, right? It's
like, "Do I really believe that the
experiment setting of the step on survey
is similar enough to mine that they will
transfer?" We can't possibly know,
right? There are always tiny
differences.
Good. Okay. So, now I get to talk about
optimizers, and I think there's been
some really exciting developments in LLM
optimizers, and maybe even deep learning
optimizers in general over the past year
or two. And so this is a exciting time
to talk about them. Um and so kind of
the story that I want to start with, and
and one that like should maybe motivate
this subsection, um is this comparison
over here. Or maybe we'll start on this
left panel, right? So, this is from um
nanoGPT speedrun, which, you know,
inspired our assignment one. And there,
you know, you have a really teeny tiny
model that you're training on a fairly
short amount of time, and you want to
get to I forgot 3.something loss as
quickly as possible, right? Um and, you
know, many people have been hill
climbing on this benchmark. And I think
one of the more, you know, remarkable
things that have happened on the
benchmark is uh as a benchmark called
Muon in in purple over here came and,
you know, got really significant gains
over Adam, which is blue. It's right
underneath the green uh line over there.
So, you know, you can just look at the
green and the purple and that gap, and
you say, "Wow, you know, lots of big
gains from just changing the optimizer
to this Muon thing." Um and it's not
even slower than Adam, much slower than
that. That's great, right?
Um but then, you know, there's a
question of like, "Well, is this thing
actually good at scale?" Um and then you
go and run some like scaling studies,
and maybe they're not quite as good. You
know, this is a really tricky and
important part of how we do research,
right? We have a small-scale experiment.
We have something that's scale-dependent
for sure, like an optimizer. Um and then
we see big gains in the small scale,
what do we do about the large scale? Um
and more than providing like a solid
concrete prescription, I I want us to
maybe almost even provide a story here
so that you can kind of get a sense of
like what we can do and what things we
can't necessarily know.
Okay. Um so, actually, before I move on
to the next slide, you know, in in this
kind of thing happens all the time.
Where you like come up with a great
thing small scale, and it just doesn't
maybe pan out large scale. So, what's
the difference? Um I'm going to spend a
few slides talking about um Kaya and uh
and sort of Tengyu and Percy and David's
paper um on basically doing a
large-scale set of experiments on
comparing optimizers and do trying to do
that comparison better. Um and there's a
lot to learn about scaling and other
things from that. But also just standard
deep learning stuff. Um you know,
there's really basic things like, you
know, the hyperparameters for different
models are different. So, if you're
scaling things up, maybe they even have
different scaling exponents. So, you
have to tune Adam really well. So, if
you tune it badly, you know, you get
this this darker brown line and you're
like, "Wow, this thing is much worse
than all these other algorithms that I
have over here on the left." But then
you you change the learning rate a
little bit and you're like, "Wow,
actually all my gains went away."
Um similarly on the right, you know, you
can have cases where maybe you've tuned
your learning rate well, but now you've
got other stuff like weight decay that
is not optimally tuned. And so, if you
use the same weight decay, then you're
certainly going to get a much worse
result for this green line, right? If
you pick this, you know, small weight
decay, you'll get a much worse result
for this green line um than if you pick
the optimal weight decay, right? So,
there's all sorts of like pretty tricky
things going on. Technically not a
scaling thing, but a very important, you
know, general empirical machine learning
thing that I want to point out.
Um but maybe more relevant to the
discussion um in this class right now is
the scale dependence of these things.
And I think this is a good sort of case
study and example of how to really think
about algorithm development as a
function of scale. Because to me, you
know, there are two variables that are
always important when thinking about
scale. And this paper exposes to some
ex- to most extent like both of them.
Um so, one axis is compute. And, you
know, if you're fixing the compute or
sorry, if you're fixing the model size
to data ratio, like the two are coupled
together, then this is essentially a
compute axis on the x-axis here, right?
So, you always want to, you know,
whenever you're doing a study, you know,
essentially scale up the compute and
look at the trends as a function of
uh of scale. And we see right here that
if we look at the relative speedup
between uh Adam, which is at 1.0 by
definition, and all these other
alternatives, we see that, you know,
MuON is really good at small scale and
that gain sort of diminishing down
diminishes down as we increase in scale.
That's That's not really necessarily
um the picture that you want to see.
Um there's another axis that that should
always be vigilant of if you're doing
algorithm development. And the other one
that you should be vigilant of is the
Chinchilla ratio. So, the Chinchilla
ratio can be thought of
it is the ratio between, you know, how
much data you have and the amount of
model you have, right? And this is a
really, really, really important
parameter because some algorithms work
well in kind of the over parameterized
case where you have a way bigger model
than you have lots of data, right? Maybe
your your algorithm adds some implicit
regularization, right? Or maybe it, you
know, is data inefficient but it works
well because of compute resources,
right? So, you know, some algorithms
might work well at the small Chinchilla
ratio case. Uh in contrast, you know,
other algorithms might work well in the
large Chinchilla ratio case where you
have lots of data per
um per uh unit parameter, right? Because
you can pack knowledge more efficiently
into the parameters, right?
So, this is a big, big, big confounder.
Even papers that I think have pretty
good hygiene in doing scaling
experiments on the model size axis often
uh neglect to or just don't have the
compute to sort of study the Chinchilla
sort of token to to parameter ratio and
this turns out to be surprisingly
important a lot of time. In this case,
it's not. In this case, you know, you
see that um the optimizer sort of gains
are pretty consistent. The ratios
between all the lines are the same at
different Chinchilla ratios, but this is
not always the case. You always want to
be vigilant about both of these scaling
factors. That's quite important.
And then I'm going to, you know, also
point out, you know, if you have a new
algorithm or a new setting, right? Um
establishing scaling is quite
non-trivial, right? So, um I've taken
this from uh one of
uh Will Held who was working with
Moraine which was, you know, Percy's
open-source language model training
project. Um and there, you know, they
were basically trying to prove out a
particular set of hyper parameters. This
isn't even like a new algorithm. So,
this is Cautious Adam C which is like a
Adam variant, um square root batch size
scaling and a and a bunch of other sort
of standard looking things. And you
know, they're doing essentially the same
sort of Chinchilla analysis that you've
seen all the other papers do. Um but
because this is not necessarily a paper,
this is a bunch of, you know, people
doing experiments, you don't just
publish the the successful one, you
know, they have the niceness of
publishing their failed runs.
Um and the example here is that they're
doing basically standard Chinchilla
stuff and it's looking great. If you if
you go up to this dashed vertical line
at 10 to the 20-something, you know,
this is a this is a really beautiful
looking scaling law to here. And then,
you know, as you scale up, it's like,
well, it's a little bit worse, it's a
lot worse and then wow, now that run is
not so good anymore, right? So, it's a
totally blown up on you.
Um and the point here is that, you know,
even good-looking scaling trends for
many orders of magnitude can suddenly
kind of bite you, right? Like it can
deviate from linear and then it can
then, you know, kind of blow up
immediately. And in their case, you
know, the the fix here is just picking
more careful μP style parameterizations,
um optimizer changes, they switch to a
pretty a different kind of optimizer,
and you know, they get nicer scaling
across boarder orders of magnitude. But
the point here
is to say, you know, when I go back here
and I say, "Okay, well, you should all
do scaling experiments, you should scale
all your learning rates and so on." Um
that's not easy, right? You you end up
in fairly non-trivial fraction of the
time with plots that look like this,
um and it's all kind of horrible and
you're not quite sure what has gone
wrong.
Um
Good. Okay.
And then so, the last thing um I want to
end with is just talking a little bit
about μon and sort of, you know, the
closing up of the μon nuance story.
Um so, you know, I I feel like I have to
talk about μon in a little bit more
detail than I already have, um just
because it's beginning to be
uh integrated into a large-scale model
training runs. Um that's kind of the
inclusion criteria for a lot of, you
know, new research topics for the class,
you know, has it been in a big training
run? And μon now checks that mark. Um
and it's also just kind of an
interesting algorithm, so I'll mention
it uh and talk about it for a few
minutes and then move on.
So, in gradient descent, we usually have
a fairly simple thing that's happening.
Ignore line four for the moment, or
sorry, line uh five for the moment. And
then you're going to get roughly a
standard, you know, uh momentum-based
optimizer, right? I take a gradient, I
uh add it to B of T, this is my momentum
step, right? So, I I
continue my momentum from before with
parameter mu, and then I update my
parameters based on this momentum
gradient. Very standard, you know,
momentum gradient stuff.
But then I think the really interesting,
and to me at least a bit of an
out-of-the-box set of ideas is to say,
"Well, you know, gradients have this
property that they treat all the
parameters are the same." But we know
that not all the parameters in uh a
language model, or even a deep neural
network, are the same. Some parameters
are like vector parameters, like they
belong to the RMS norm.
Some parameters are matrix parameters,
like for the attention or for MLPs,
right? And matrix parameters are
probably different than vector
parameters. And so, that's kind of the
starting point for this idea, and I
think a really interesting one. Um, and
so, the one thing that you could do
about matrix parameters is you can start
to look at their spectra, right? Like
they're matrices, matrices have
eigenvalues and singular values. And so,
you can do things to the singular
values. And so, um what you do here in
in Muon is this fairly simple idea. You
compute a gradient, you take a momentum
step.
And now I take my update B of T, and
instead of directly applying it to my
parameters in line six, what I'm going
to do is I'm going to do this
Newton-Schultz thing, Newton-Schultz
five to be specific. Um, and what that
is is it's going to orthogonalize
the B of T matrix. Um, and so, I've
written the operation down there on the
bottom, you know, let's say I take B of
T, I write it as singular uh value
decomposition, USV transpose, and then I
make all of my singular values one,
right? So, if my singular values are
really big, I'll shrink them back to
unit. If they're really small, I'll
expand them back up to being unit. And
then I take UV transpose, and that's my
new update that I'm going to apply,
right?
Um if you want intuition for this, and
you already have intuition for something
like Adagrad or these other or Adam
even,
in Adagrad or Adam, you're going to
divide by kind of the size of the
gradient, right? So, every coordinate is
roughly going to be the same size. Um in
MuON, you are operating in the spectral
norm instead, so every kind of direction
is going to be unit size, right? And
notice that this only makes sense for a
matrix. I can only define this notion of
a of a singular value decomposition for
a matrix value B of T, right? So, um the
interesting thing about MuON is it's a
matrix optimizer. So, you apply it to
these matrix value parameters, and for
the vector valued ones, you know, you
might still use something like AdamW,
right? Cuz those don't really have any
sort of interaction with the
Newton-Schultz term.
Oh, also, Newton-Schultz is a is a
approximation to that operation that
only uses matrix multiplies, right? So,
it's systems efficient and not exactly
the the orthogonalization. Um
but okay, like why have I spent, you
know, all this time talking about MuON?
Well, first of all, it's very, you know,
powerful for things like the nanoGPT
speed run. It was discovered for this,
you know, set of things.
And so, you might think that it works
well.
As I said in the previous slide, you
know, there have been some scaling
studies that have argued that the gain
for MuON sort of decreases as scale goes
up.
But then, you know, I kind of want to
close off this story, which, you know, I
think initially this came out and I was
like, "Wow, MuON's kind of interesting.
I wonder if anyone will scale it up."
And then Kai Yu and other others scaled
up MuON and they said, "Well, maybe it
doesn't work super well." And I thought
the story was kind of closed here. I was
like, "Well, maybe this is done. No one
will spend the big compute to to scale
this guy up to the full pre-training
size." And then Kimmy K2 comes out, Um,
and that whole model is trained with
MuON, um, like fully with MuON with a
few bells and whistles to prevent MuON
from like blowing up on you. They found
a whole bunch of instability issues. Um,
but Kimmy K2 is an outstandingly good
model, right? Like they're very good
model, um, and the training curves look,
you know, reasonable. Um, and so really
what this suggests is like, well, you
know, MuON worked at scale. Like is it
better than Adam? Kimmy K2 certainly
doesn't have any ablation, so we will
don't know at that scale, but it is
certainly a valid and workable solution.
Um, and so what's the point of this
story? It's to say it's really hard to
know whether something works at scale.
It's very, very hard. Um, but thus far a
lot of like small scale experiments and
transferring them up to large scale has
been the way by which we do science,
right? And so, you know, you still want
to respect things like the Nano GPT
speed run. We learn quite a bit from
that and get good ideas, and then
eventually they make their way to the
big models. We'll see if, you know,
people continue to do ablations at big
scale and really nail down, you know, is
MuON better than AdamW at scale and so
on. Those are interesting questions to
which we don't yet have the answers.
Okay.
Um, I'll pause here for a moment. This
is the end of my optimizer section. I
want to make sure everyone's good. Also,
especially cuz I I was talking about
MuON and that's a whole new can of worms
that I haven't talked about much before.
Yeah.
Okay.
Right. Yeah, the question was is SVD
fast on GPUs? SVD is not fast on GPUs,
but they're not doing SVD. What they're
doing is Newton-Schulz. Newton-Schulz is
a matrix multiply only finite iteration
algorithm that approximates the process
of orthogonalizing a matrix.
Um, so there's like kind of several
clever pieces here. One of them is kind
of the idea of like treating it as a
matrix on its own, and then there's this
orthogonalization idea, and then there's
a systems piece of doing it with
Newton-Schulz. So those are all like
important, interesting pieces. Yeah,
back there.
>> What are the hyperparameters for MuON
here?
Um,
Adam for the AdamW ones.
>> Uh I have the hyper parameter share. No,
they're they're different. Yeah. Um I
think you know, there's several people
that uh have been working on this like
muP style line of work. Um and one of
them I think like Jeremy Bernstein, you
know, I think he he's been saying like
actually like every layer should have
its own learning rate. You know, I think
the the ultimate limit of this is like,
you know, you go from or even I'm sorry.
Like every layer should have its own
optimizer, right? Um the ultimate limit
of this is to say every parameter in a
transformer is different, why not have a
different optimizer for each one of
them, right?
>> And so you would have to do the hyper
parameters for each one of them as well.
Which I do not want to do, but you know,
that's maybe the future of of
optimization. Yes.
>> What's the
the limit of the hyper
like they're only learning rate and
batch size, like they just consider like
these two things and then you pick the
best out of those and then you kind of
use it to determine other things.
But do these things like
interact with each other?
>> Yeah, or maybe the the version of the
question that I interpreted was, you
know, a lot of these people are just
tuning learning rate and batch size and
do they do this on the grid, but
presumably these things interact with a
whole bunch of other hyper parameters,
aren't you worried about that? And I
think in general, yes, you are worried
about hyper parameter interactions, but
realistically they grow they grow
exponentially, right? Like this is not a
thing where you can grid out the whole
space. Um and so I think the the thing
that people often do is they grid the
stuff that's most concerning and most
sensitive and learning rates are very
important. I think if you you know, ever
tune stuff, learning rates are the most
important thing to tune, so they very
aggressively go on that. And then stuff
like weight decay, they might do a
univariate sweep afterwards, right? To
to be locally optimal with respect to
those parameters.
Good. Okay.
All right. So the final part of this
lecture is I want to talk about muP. Um
muP is a bit of a mysterious object.
Even with many papers written about it
and sort of in fact even many
implementations, uh
um I don't think all of them even agree
on what the underlying math is or what
the underlying implementation should be.
Um but there's a core set of ideas that
are shared and it does seem generally
effective. And so I'll talk about
my interpretation of the whole program,
let's call it. Um so the goal,
hopefully, is very clear and I think
this picture is the goal. The picture
being, well, if we increase the size of
our model, in this case just width, our
optimal learning rate normally shifts,
but ideally we want the optimal learning
rate to be the same no matter what.
Right, that is the game that we would
like to play and the knobs that I'm
willing to tune to do this is I'm
willing to mess with the initializations
at a per layer basis. I'm willing to
mess with the learning rates on a per
parameter basis as well. Um and then I'm
sometimes willing to scale up or down
things like residual connections, right,
based on my the size of my model.
Okay, so that's the game that I'd like
to play. Um and how well does it work in
practice? There's been several papers
that have studied these fairly
extensively. Um Cerebras Cerebras, which
is really a chip company, um also has a
language model training arm, um run by
Hessness of the scaling law, you know,
paper fame. Um and they actually, I feel
like they have they do very interesting
things because they now are writing lots
of papers about new P scaling of
language models.
Um and they have Cerebras GPT uh from a
couple of years ago where they were
training, you know, the 0.1 to 13B
models using the usual Chinchilla
recipe, but also including a muP variant
which they used to try to to tune the
hyperparameters more effectively.
Um and I think one of the the nice
things about this is they find that, you
know, if they use the muP
parametrization,
um then their scaling law fits are
generally more stable. Their their
projected muP trends are, you know,
almost right on the money for their
actual models, whereas I think their
their non-MUP models sort of fluctuated
much more wildly in terms of the loss
predictions that they had. And so their
claim was, "Okay, MUP is maybe a really
good idea."
So this is validated at scale. You saw
many CPM and others.
Many people have trained models with MUP
variants.
Um
So I could also talk a lot about, you
know, training or examples of models
trained with MUP, but I think maybe the
more interesting thing for me to do
right now is actually to talk about the
conceptual foundations and the math sort
of for MUP. And if you're interested in
this and you want to read a somewhat
accessible paper, I would recommend this
one. This is the paper that I think
for me was the clearest.
Um there are several papers. Greg Yang,
who who kind of started this research
program, has a series of papers all
called tensor programs. I find them
somewhat inscrutable. Um Jeremy
Bernstein, you know, who was also
working on the MUP one stuff, has
written this nice sort of
re- not recap paper, like a like a
review paper sort of putting it into a
different framework, which I think is
very accessible. Um and there are
several others by physicists that are
also um interesting in terms of
explaining what MUP is. The the Cerebras
people actually do a bit of that as
well.
Okay.
But anyway, returning to this paper, um
the core idea of MUP is based off of two
kind of assertions, right? And this is a
very physicist way of thinking about
this. So if I make my network big, let's
say I'm I'm only changing the width for
now, right? I'm making the width of my
network big, um I'm going to assert two
invariants that should hold as I do the
scaling limit. First of all, um the
activations at initialization, so if I
initialize my model and I put in some
random data, the activations should
remain the same size roughly as a
function of the network, right? So if
they blow up with the network size or
they shrink to zero with the network
size, I have chosen a wrong
parametrization. And that kind of makes
sense, right? If my activation should be
roughly the same scale um regardless of
the size of my network.
Now, after one gradient step, um, the
change in my activations should be O of
1, right? So, this is what people call
feature learning. So, feature learning
means if I take a gradient step, things
in my network change a significant
amount. And that this amount should be a
fixed function of the width of the
network. Um, in case,
you know, some of you are theorists,
right? You know, you might be uh
familiar with neural tangent kernels.
Neural tangent kernels would have a very
different behavior. Those would be the
kinds of things where the change in
activations actually vanish as a
function of the of the network width.
And you don't want that because you do
want the network to change and learn
features and do things even in the limit
of your big sort of neural networks.
Okay, so these two are the invariants.
They kind of make sense. They're
basically saying activations and the
change in the activations should remain
roughly similar as a function of the
width of the network. And then, um, note
that I'm going to sometimes go back and
forth between individual activations,
which is this, and then the norm, which,
you know, if each activation is roughly
O of 1, the norm of the whole vector uh
of activation should be square root of
the number of hidden units in that
layer.
Okay. So, that's the main thing.
Now, the thing about μP is it's kind of
interesting because it starts with, you
know, this very, uh, simple and
palatable set of assumptions. You might
all agree that this is a reasonable
thing to do. And then we're going to
make a, um,
a number of additional strong
assumptions, but then in the end, we're
going to get a very simple set of
scaling rules that drop out of this. Um,
so, remember what we want to do is we
want to make sure that the activations
at init are roughly unit. So, what do we
do? Well, if we have a simple deep
linear network, and we initialize all of
our weights as a sigma squared, you
know, scaled Gaussian, um, then what is
going to be kind of the spectral norm of
this matrix? Well, you can write that
down, right? I'm not going to ask you to
verify that, but that's, you know,
standard matrix concentration arguments
for the operator norm of a random
Gaussian matrix. And then, now note that
in, you know, certain regimes where the
fan out is, I think, not much bigger
than the fan in, you're going to get
that the output of the layer is kind of
similar to the product of the input of
the layer times the operator norm,
right? This is always an upper bound,
but this is, you know, approximate in
certain high-dimensional regimes.
Now, if this is true, now what can we
do? Well, we can solve for sigma to try
to keep our activations the same across
all of the layers and across all the
width. So, imagine that at layer at L
minus 1, um I have sort of square root
of L minus 1 uh activation. And this is,
remember, you know, consistent with this
notation that, you know, at least for
this whole vector, I should have square
root of N over L, right? So, this is our
our base case for our induction, and
then our inductive case says, well, you
know, remember that I have this operator
norm at layer L, which is this function
of the fan in and the fan out. And so,
this is going to be equal to this if I
pick a particular sigma. So, let's say
uh this is the ansatz. I'm going to
assume that this is the answer, and then
we'll see what happens to the induction.
If I pick this as a hypothesis and I
plug this into the sigma, notice that I
get that the ratio of the operator norm
is this, the ratio of the fan out over
the sorry, square root of the fan out
over the square root of the fan in. And
then I plug this back in here, and then
I'm going to get that the norm of the
output is going to be equal to the
square root of the number of units in my
layer plus some lower order terms that
I'm not going to bother to keep track
of, right? So, you know, where this
sigma came out of, I mean, this is, you
know, drawing it out of a hat, but we
can kind of verify that if I, you know,
plug this sort of noise initialization
into my formula, then essentially at
every layer, the size of my activations
is roughly equal to the square root of
the number of hidden units at that
layer, right? Um there are some
assumptions made here like this
approximate equals, but this is like
mostly a legitimate uh set of
assumptions. So, condition A1's pretty
simple.
Um condition A2 is a little bit hairier,
to be honest.
Um so, really we need to deal with the
updates now, and um I'm only going to
consider the case of a single example in
a batch for SGD for uh linear neural
network, so deep linear network. Um so,
what is this going to look like? Well,
the change in my uh weights for a
particular layer L, um you know, if you
think about how this is going to behave,
it's going to be a rank one update
between my gradient for the loss and
sort of the activations, right? This is
true, you know, just because of the
behavior of the backwards, right? The
forwards is a rank one multiplication,
the backwards is going to be a rank one
outer product.
Um so, now, you know, this is the change
in the weights, and now what is the
change in the activations at that layer?
Well, the change in the activations, you
know, I just take H equals W times HL
minus one, and I expand this out, right?
And I expand this out into this formula.
This is going to be exactly the change
in the activation at layer L, and it's
going to have two terms, one that is
sort of the direct term from changes in
the activation at L minus one, and the
cross term in some sense of what happens
because my weights have changed, not
just because the activations at the
previous layer have changed, right? So,
there's two terms to this uh to this
update, and so this is kind of the
change in the activation at layer L.
And now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to look through each of these
three terms. I want each of these three
terms to have the same order of
magnitude, and I want that order of
magnitude to be square root of n of L.
Why is that? Remember that, you know, if
I go back two slides, the condition that
I want for A2 is that after one gradient
step, the change in activation should be
O of one or omega of one. And so, if I
want that to be true, then the norm of
that layer should be square root of n L.
And so, to do that, what I want is for
each of these three terms to be to have
that order of magnitude, and if that's
true and there's no cancellations, um
then this, you know, is going to be the
right order of magnitude. You can kind
of see the sketchy pieces adding up,
right? We're assuming things like no
cancellations and so on, but this is
giving us some interesting ways of
thinking about the magnitude of each of
these objects. So, you know, at this
point, you know, the the right thing way
to think about this is not like, okay,
Tatsu is sitting here doing like
rigorous mathematics. You know, what I
am doing here is I'm basically keeping
track of all of the orders of magnitude
of all the terms, and I am saying that
given our assumptions, how big should
these roughly be? It's like kind of
physicist math, um no offense to
physicists. Um this was developed by
physicists in this way. Okay. Um
Okay. So, now really Oh, sorry. Go go
back one slide just uh to make all this
clear. Um so, the first term, this comes
by almost assumption, right? It's kind
of the inductive assumption. We assume
that delta H of L minus 1 has the right
order of magnitude, right? So, this
comes for free.
Um These other two terms, these are
trickier. We have these terms that
multiply um the change in my weights in
operator norm times square root of L
minus 1. And so, because these two are
the sort of orders of magnitudes of both
of these terms, we kind of know how big
this delta L needs to be, right? We can
solve for this because we know that this
left-hand side needs to be square root n
L, and then we have this term, so we
solve for this operator norm, and that's
exactly this quantity, right? So, so
this is going to be the goal for the
next slide. I want to make I want to try
to figure out what kinds of learning
rates are going to give me an update
that's roughly scaled as the square root
of the fan out over the square root of
the fan in. Right? So, that's the goal.
Right? As I said, after I pick a
learning rate, this should roughly be
true. So, how can we do that?
Well, we're going to make yet another
assumption, and this is probably the
least palatable of the assumptions in my
opinion, which is that we're going to
assume that the, you know, the loss
update is going to be scaled by unit. In
other words, you know, we're going to
assume that, you know, our model is
actually making some appreciable
non-trivial progress as a function of
scale and that that's roughly similar.
Not quite sure that's palatable to me,
but that is yet another assumption. So,
we throw that down. But now, the the
point of this assumption is that if this
is true, the rest of the math works out
quite cleanly because the change in the
loss is, you know, the product of my
gradient plus how much my weights
change. This is Taylor approximation.
And then, because this is rank one, I
can rewrite this thing as a Frobenius
norm and as an operator norm.
Um and so, this right-hand side now
allows us to to get what we want. This
is O of one. This term we want to be
square root NL over square root L minus
one. That's this term on the right here.
And then finally, I have this gradient
of L term. Um and this is going to be
square root of NL minus one over square
root NL. And then so, now what eta do I
need? Well, the eta that I need is going
to be solving for this quantity, which
is the ratio of these two guys, which is
NL over NL minus one. Right? So, um we
made this one assumption that the
left-hand side of this is O of one, and
then we've solved for all the
quantities, and we've ended up with a
fan out over fan in ratio for a learning
rate for our layer. Um for one side note
that I'll make is that for Adam, because
of kind of the changes in in some of
this, um you're going to get like a one
over NL minus one scaling, which I'll
I'll mention here.
Okay. Um so, I've walked through a bunch
of kind of hopefully intuitive-looking
scaling arguments for various
components. Um but in the end, maybe you
are interested in like what does this
mean? What does this do for me? Um
what this means is that we're going to
change how we um set our initializations
and learning rates a little bit. Um
so, our initialization is going to look
like So, for mu P, the blue box is kind
of what we do. Our initialization is
going to be one over square root NL
minus one times a component that is one
over the square root fan out over fan
in. So, if this is one, then this is
equivalent to the usual initialization.
This is the standard parameterization,
but if this ratio is not smaller than
one, then you get basically something
different. You get something that's
closer to the square root fan out over
fan in.
The learning rate, normally you would
set to be a constant as a function of
your model size, but you would want to
set this to the ratio of fan out and fan
in. And maybe more interestingly for
Adam, this whole thing is a little bit
more different. I'm not going to even
touch the derivation for that, um where
you drop this one over uh NL term and
you get one over the fan in as kind of
the layer specific learning rate. Um and
so basically layers that have big fan
ins for Adam get smaller learning rates.
It allows you to have these layer
adaptive learning rates that are quite
interesting.
Okay.
Um so, that was kind of the derivation
of μP. Um
maybe, you know, I went through a lot of
details. I do want to maybe talk about
what the high-level point of that was.
And the high-level point of that is μP
as sort of a argument is very
interesting. Not only is there like
actual useful stuff, the way in which
you get to the algorithm is itself
interesting because it's this very
different kind of math in which you're
saying, "Okay, you know, I'm going to
take a scaling limit of my network and
then I assert some invariants about my
network and then I'm going to make
additional assumptions and then I'm
going to try to figure out what the
constraints on my sort of
hyperparameters are." And the
constraints essentially give you certain
kinds of scaling limits on your
hyperparameters as well. Right? So, this
is a general principle for coming up
with different kinds of algorithms or
hyperparameter scalings, I think which
are probably very different than what
you're used to um in CS or ML training.
So.
Okay. That was the μP derivation. Um
I want to close out on the μP part with
just a few like empirical things. Um
there's an interesting paper by a
independent researcher um on basically
stress testing μP in lots of different
ways.
Um and μP can be, you know, thought of
as a as a proceed procedure for tuning
hyper parameters.
And so, you know, depending on how you
do things like, you know, Adam is going
to have a certain learning rate as a
function of different components of the
network. So, you have an embedding
parameter, attention parameters, input
output MLPs or softmax linears. All of
those are going to have different kinds
of scalings
under mu P as well as
not mu P scaling rules.
And the interesting thing here
is that particular paper, you know,
replicated a bunch of the mu P results
for
language models trained at different
scales. And maybe unsurprisingly, he
found, you know, almost the headline
result from
mini CPM and others, which is that if
you get the mu P right and you're only
scaling with in this case in a very
controlled way,
you get exactly the learning rate
optimality invariance that, you know,
baseline mu P or just looking at kind of
a variant of mu P that sort of tracks.
Projection biases for attention, both of
those transfer very nicely.
But then, you might ask
you know,
basically, there's a lot of things in
the real world that mu P does not
handle, right? Like, technically, Swiglu
does not fit into mu P. Neither does,
you know, initialize variations
initialization or RMS norm. Or if you
really mess with your optimizer, that
will mess that up, too. Um and so, you
might ask like which of these like, you
know, things that are not allowed by the
theory really break mu P. And actually,
for the most part, these mostly work
with mu P. But some of the things that
don't work is if you, you know, learn
the gain term in RMS norm. This turns
out to break mu P. Although, these can
be removed in many cases without
necessarily
hurting you. And so, maybe it's not such
a bad idea. But this does seem to break
mu P.
It also seems to break if you use more
exotic optimizers like Lion, which
basically rely on the sign of the
gradient. And this is sign gradient is
kind of like a spiritually similar to mu
on and other ideas. And so, there might
be other interesting things that break
with mu P as well.
Um finally, the thing that seems most
concerning is that if you do large
decoupled weight decay, um you end up
with uh significant mu P failure. So,
this is maybe the one stress test that
it does fail. Um
But to close out this final section, you
know, you might in the end ask like is
mu P useful? Um and if you really want
to stabilize your learning rates, it is
actually pretty useful.
Um there's a lot of experiments of this
form where, you know, if you increase
the width, your optimal learning rate
shifts very predictably, but, you know,
very greatly as a function of scale,
whereas with mu P it doesn't. And so,
it's one of the many tools in the
toolkit to try to control hyperparameter
drift as a function of scale. Um I think
it's an interesting open area of
research. It's not really sort of, you
know, done and dusted and like this is
the one right thing to do, but there's a
lot of promise in the sort of the mu P
style initialization program. There's
also a lot of promise in just fitting
scaling laws as well.
Okay.
So, final thing I want to close with,
you know, scaling in the wild is very
tricky. As I sort of mentioned in one of
my replies, you know, I think the
initial presentation of scaling laws
makes it sound like a science, right?
Like it's like, yes, draw this line, do
these procedures, and you will know for
sure what will happen at scale.
Um but I think in reality it's a lot
more messy and a lot more unknown than
that. Um you know, there are lots of
things that people do use in practice
scaling laws for, like picking
architectures, picking optimizers,
picking hyperparameters, right? All of
these things are things that people do
with scaling laws, but there is really
an art to it in the sense of you don't
really know if it's truly going to
extrapolate forever. You want to do sort
of reasonable things to maximize the
chances of success, right? And so,
there's lots of solutions that people
have. You can use mu P, you can search
for the optimal learning rate and all of
these other kinds of things and these
are ways of controlling hyper parameter
drift but there's no silver bullet yet.
Maybe next year there will be module
that's like we solved it but not quite
yet.
Great. Thanks a lot.
I can take questions afterwards.